when the band was Miami Sound Machine
yes so at some point you figured out
screw these guys
well this is always interesting to me
you say look let's face it I mean
they're terrific but I could get anybody
to back me up but I'm gonna go sit and
talk to these guys and say look I want
it to be Gloria Stefan and Miami Sound
Machine okay but that is a major thing
to have to sit and tell a group of guys
when they were just when all well how
did it all start yeah we don't have the
whole story here yeah good but I love it
give me the real story I'll give you
this Coop Miami sound machine is my
husband Emilio I joined his band he
started it with his accordion alone oh
in Miami and he would add pieces because
he did it for fun he used to do
accordion for tips in restaurants and he
worked since he was 15. right in the
mail room at Bacardi and one of the guys
says to him hey come over to my house
I'm gonna have a party he went with his
accordion they loved it they go next
time you think you could bring some more
band members he goes okay he hired a
drummer percussionist and by the time I
joined there was like nine people in the
band already but it was all it was my
husband so he's the one that came to me
and says I want to add your name first
and I go why are you going to add my
name he goes okay they just invited you
plus you Domingo to sing with them on
this album and what are you going to put
plastic those things with the girl from
Miami Sound Machine he goes you need to
have your name out there but then at
some point you even like dumped the
whole sound well because at that point
Emilio was no longer performing on stage
either so he said forget the the name
and I was on when I was touring it's
always it's still Miami Sound Machine
with me some guys since 1985 same guys